in this neighborhood in the east side of
the valley trees were ripped right out
of the ground we're tracking all the
damage and the possibility of more
storms on the way with Team coverage
tonight but before we get over to your
forecast with Jerry Brown let's go out
live to Madison Kimbrough for a look at
some of the damage from last night
Madison
yeah Sasha I know you said that you were
out here last night you saw it for
yourself but now we're about to show it
to viewers as you can see uprooted trees
and debris everywhere not to mention
intense damage to these units and houses
in the area now take a look at this this
is probably the most shocking scene that
you're going to see this enormous
uprooted tree that fell on top of this
car Friday night's weather a Continuum
of what we have seen and it's been
experiencing these last couple days many
people having to evacuate their homes
due to safety the residents here at the
lake Sahara Apartments say last night's
ordeal was startling and they're worried
that tonight may be a repeat we spoke to
the man who owns that damaged car you
just saw a little bit ago about the
whole ordeal turns out he was inside the
car parked and texting when the tree
fell on top
I noticed that this tree the bushes was
on my front windshield and before I
could even react I just started hearing
glass breaking it lasted for about maybe
I say 10 seconds it was a long 10
seconds and um as soon as everything
just stopped you know I was still alive
I just exited out the vehicle you know
luckily the driver door wasn't
um damaged or I was stuck inside
for many residents it's still unclear
when they will be able to move back in
but at least three buildings were
evacuated the Red Cross says they are
assisting 30 people displaced by this
Monsoon they're currently at Orr middle
school so we hope to talk to the Red
Cross later on today if you have any
questions you were urged to call 1-800
Red Cross for help